see youtubers we are Groot a lot of you
are asking me about the Guardians
characters that are going to be in
infinity war there were some new
confirmation so there's going to be a
breakdown there's a whole bunch of
Guardian stuff it's going to be
happening in the next couple weeks
they're going to start their official
marketing campaign for the movie so
you'll start seeing a whole bunch of
stuff they started teasing all the toys
and stuff so I'll be doing some fun
giveaways but for now new round of the
spider-man giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video it's a $20
comiXology gift card so I'm going to
start with the really big characters and
work my way down through the new ones to
mostly focusing on the new ones because
there are a lot of new people in this
film we haven't seen before like mantis
but they're all from the comics they're
going to be awesome let's just start
with mantis so a lot of you are probably
familiar with the Mantis character if
you've been reading the guardians of the
galaxy comic for a while then most of
you probably know the annihilation
conquest version who is recruited by
star-lord and used her abilities to sort
of hypnotize convince the other members
of the team to join up the really
interesting thing about that comic book
arc and the reason why you should
probably go back and reread it at some
point is because the annihilation
conquest was all about the attack from
the Phalanx upon the galaxy led by
Ultron who had been fired into outer
space
after the Mighty Avengers arc which is
basically the storyline did they adapted
for Avengers age of Ultron so you have
to imagine that Ultron in the continuity
right now is just hiding out somewhere
probably buried in visions programming
but in the comics what they did is they
fired
Ultron into deep space he landed on the
Phalanx and was able to take over their
techno based culture and they became
this scourge on the galaxy which
inspired star-lord to put a team
together and that became the beginning
of the modern version of the guardians
of the galaxy now the classic guardians
actually had yondu in the lineup he's
going to be in the lineup for the new
movie and unfortunately he is
unconfirmed for infinity war but I
wouldn't be surprised if he shows up he
just to unique of a character to not get
in there somewhere but along those lines
mantis yondu infinity war not all cameos
and appearances are created equal so
really like the big star of guardians of
the galaxy is star-lord
he's obviously going to have a much
bigger part in infinity war than the
other characters but really the whole
main cast is going to be coming to
infinity war at least in a small way
just some of them are going to get way
more screen time than the others like of
course there's going to be some funny
group moments with the other real
Avengers you can just picture spider-man
and Tony start flipping their lids it'll
be the coolest thing ever but the really
cool thing about mantis is that in the
comics she's actually a really badass
fighter she's almost like carnac with
the way she can sense weaknesses and use
those as exploits during fights so
that's how she can fight someone big
like Drax but in the context of the
movie her character is just a little
different so what James Gunn did is he
took the more modern version of the
character and sort of gave her the look
of the classic mantis and then weaves
her backstory in with star-lord
so she's like the half-sister of
star-lord with ego the Living Planet is
crazy as all that sounds she's just as
much of a badass is most of the other
Avengers characters there were a couple
moments where she faced Thanos clones
people think she's as powerful as Thor
but I feel like they simplify things a
little bit for the MCU movies so Thor is
go is going to be like the big tough guy
but in the way they play up those funny
moments there's a lot of tough guys on
the Guardians like Gamora is a tough guy
cracks is the tough guy there'll be all
kinds of badass jokes when they meet up
on screen I know a lot of people are
wondering about Nathan Fillion character
he's playing Simon Williams aka Wonder
Man in guardians of the galaxy so the
thing is is the way they're playing it
in the movie is that it's sort of like
an easter egg like he's an actor he's
not the actual Wonder Man from the
comics with Wonder Man's powers he just
somebody who has the name and it's going
to be a really funny thing for fans who
know who the Wonder Man character is so
they haven't said anything about
including him during infinity war but I
do think that they will include a small
Nathan Fillion Easter egg probably not a
speaking role but you see this poster in
the background here expects something
like this so technically he would be
part of infinity war without actually
having a speaking role and that's going
to be true of a lot of the lesser
characters so when we talk about
characters being infinity war just
remember that they have like 66 plus
characters that they've teased mo
of those will not be speaking roles
they'll be named on list they'll be
people that you see in the background
they're going to be very few people that
actually speak on camera and you see in
the foreground next big one is nebula
karen gillan actually t's that she was
going to be part of infinity war but she
said it wouldn't be a very big thing so
you just have to remember that she is
one of the daughters of Thanos so that
sort of justifies her presence in the
film she's really big in the Guardians
movie she's even going to be travelling
with them for a little while so there'll
be a lot of crazy Kimora nebula sisters
stuff going on so they're going to carry
that into infinity war but the other big
surprise is that cracklin Shawn Gunn's
character James Gunn's brother is going
to be an infinity war which just means
that there's going to be a Ravager stuff
going on that almost confirms that
they're going to do yondu because why
would you do a much lesser character
from the Ravagers without doing him
everyone's asking about Sylvester
Stallone's character I think he's just
going to be in guardians and really it's
just sort of like a wink if the fans the
roles that he plays it's going to be a
lot of fun but I think it's just a
one-off thing the Nova Corps will cross
over a little they haven't confirmed
Glenn Close I think it's more likely
that they would include john c reilly
because they have the power stone right
now
so because Thanos does not have that and
he's not appearing during guardians of
the galaxy - does it have to address how
he gets the Power Stone that's where the
Nova Corps comes in but deep cut
collector very important character
that's not going to be in guardians to
have to come back for infinity war
because he has the reality gem still
they gave it to him at the end of Thor
the dark world which is sort of the
connective tissue between the other film
so at the end of guardians to the
expected post credit scene is going to
be thor ragnarok just because that's the
next movie that's coming there was a
Guardians post-credit scene at the end
of the last door movie
I can assure you it will be absolutely
safe yeah in my collection see what it
is
one town
by so it just makes sense that the two
space based Marvel movies have a little
connective tissue between them because
they both dealt with really cosmic
threats infinity stone so all that
remains is what tease up thor ragnarok
we can talk about that after we see
guardians because it's actually coming
in a couple months but the really big
characters that everyone's talking about
it's probably not going to show up
during infinity war is ego the Living
Planet Kurt Russell's character he's not
expected for infinity war whatever his
arc is going to be it's going to close
with guardians to I don't think they'll
kill him off but the way James Gunn said
that he's engineered his story is that
it's still very self-contained like he
doesn't have to connect to the other
film that's really what the post-credits
scenes are for what about the actual
crossover like why would the Guardians
ever need to meet with the people on
earth well really it has to do with
star-lord learning about threats to the
earth his home so him being pulled back
there that way the biggest threat would
be Bannos with the gem so the simplest
idea would be for them to have some sort
of moment with the Asgardians or
somebody else from the Avengers really
Thor's the easiest character because
he's the only one that anybody from the
Guardians movies has actually met so
they begin their infinity quest to stop
Thanos from completing his mission that
throws them into the path of the other
earth-based Avengers so really I think
we'll see a guardian Thor crossover
before we actually see him interact with
any of the other earth-based Avengers so
if your friends ask you which guardians
are going to show up during infinity war
you could almost say all of them but
just remember that there's going to be
like two and a half hours of movie we'll
probably see a lot of those guardians
characters in less than ten minutes of
that the people you'll see on screen
most of the time will be like star-lord
Gamora Groot rocket you get the idea the
biggest characters will get the most
screen time and the same is true from
the other franchises so they'll be other
Thor characters that will crossover with
infinity war some of them will only show
up very briefly some of them like Thor
himself Valkyrie will get way more
screen time well let me know what do you
guys most excited for in guardians to I
know everybody wants to know about ego
the Living Planet there's so many
mind-boggling possibilities just
explaining the way
so he was able to fashion himself a
human body so that he could have a child
with a human woman but just a reminder
the Disney's supposed to be promoting
guardians of the galaxy in the new
Pirates movie during the Superbowl so
whenever they drop new footage I will
totally do a video for it so it's going
to be awesome and there will be a whole
bunch of other Super Bowl trailer videos
that I'll do what you guys wait for that
to post you can click here to rewatch
the Guardians trailer again and you can
click here to learn about what's going
on with Black Panther they just started
filming thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
in the next video